Hãy con phân thâm, với phong độ tháng hoa đang còn những bước tiến thực hiện mạnh mẽ.
Nếu này hửa hẹn sẽ mang đến nhiều dịch biệt khó lượng cho sải đấu.
Giải đấu liên của nhau gờ đăng bi đến những sợ đấu của cùng với nhiều bất ngờ và tích tính.
Sao dại đợt một nền tượng với mề bà chiếm mề buồn trên thắng,
APT East Squad được xem nợ ứng cư ghét hàng đầu trong môi vô địch.
Thuy nhiên, khi bước Squad dạy đợt thải của Phong Leop, lưỡ tiện này đã bắt đầu chính là khi để thù hài lên,
khi có phần thâm, qua đó, mốt phải vượt của 1st thà nếu môi xin quyền phong mặt tại chiếm chung két tồng.
Ở chung ở lại, xa con phân thâm đang phải gẹp con độ khu thí em tượng,
sau linh thay đổi chính phột và nhìn sửu, giúp lỗi nhìn trong vừa lên dẫn đầu chính bà xe vạc.
Với sự ordic và bạn lính thí đấu đến gào, xa con phân thâm đã sẽ thành lộ đầu tiên dành bế vạch chung két tồng,
và sức xa sẽ đợi tuổi của mề được mặt với họ, vó ngày 2 tháng mi một tế đây.
Và hài đón xem tháng bộ dịch biến của các chạp đấu này, xin các nền tạm của với tế vạc, và không còn lại,
nó lại tìm đi, hoặc lơ s và với tế vạc.